du willst so nicht verhalten bist du
herzlich willkommen zu tag 2 von dem
video dales und tag 3 von einer
videoreihe und allgemeinen befindet
welcher tag ist heute heute sagen wir
werden jetzt mit einem taxi zu dem video
days fahren wir sind noch ein bisschen
angeschlagen von gestern weil wir
gestern noch bei der google party waren
jedenfalls wir sind morgens aufgewacht
und gestern abend ist uns das irgendwie
voll nicht aufgefallen da gucke ich
offen tisch liegt auf einmal so ein
zettel so liebe gäste bitte melden sie
sich an der rezeption vielen dank einer
ahnung also wir werden jetzt mal zur
rezeption vielleicht gar nicht ein
bisschen was undercover film was da
genau passiert ist und
der taxifahrer gesagt also jedenfalls
nicht angekommen wir sind jetzt auf der
etwas zu essen weil wir ein reiches
gestern nichts getrunken wir haben
einfach nur dieses ähnliche chancen das
hat auch wieder gefühlte zehn jahre her
jetzt wollen wir uns irgendwas und dann
gesperrt
dann halt nicht so krass lehre nicht
gestört aber wo man halt so ein bisschen
uhr hat und was es kann
wir werden jetzt diskutiert zu dem
konzert von passport anschauen wollten
und
darf ich mal das ja wissen was nehmen
kann da vorne steht
du bist erst download heim mit uns
und wir sind schon die ganze idee wie
wir da unten durchkommen ohne dass die
idee gefunden
wahrscheinlich gehört die aufnahmen
gesehen wo über die bühne gelaufen sind
die hat nämlich glücklicherweise
bereitgestellt jedenfalls wenn wir etwas
essen gehen dass alles schön aussehen
lassen
gucken und danach mal schauen was da
noch jeder soll dann zu einem ja ich
hoffe euch hat der heutige tag ist er
gefallen und jetzt natürlich noch weiter
in der wohnung eine kompetente erkennt
die ideen das ist meine karte dabei nie
genug ist so ein unfassbar schöne
auslegen ein bisschen gesagt zu geben
aber es ist einfach viel zu schön
ich hab jetzt auf die füße grad
herunterbaumeln und eventuell nicht dass
wir mehr zeigen das sind halt schon so
acht neun stockwerke oder so aber es ist
einfach so schön das ist wahrscheinlich
die aufnahme gerade gesehen noch kurz
vor dem essen und zwar war das 1
du kommst in den block to figure
medias kraft party die ist bestimmt
irgendwo her
freunde wir fangen hier fünf partien der
ich wünsche euch allen auf jeden fall
noch eine wunderbare nacht gehören
gerade zwieback und den ganzen schüssel
sind scheiße müde
wir haben wie sieht unsere unterwäsche
einfach auf das bett geknallt und haben
gehofft dass sie dass das aufräumen als
wir haben einfach das auch spaß gemacht
und so checken ob das machen aber die
habe ich hier unten in die ecke liege
jedenfalls wieder zurück auf dem
hotelzimmer wie immer wieso bekommen das
schon gut aber den ganzen tag einfach
nur so schupp und ruhig mal wieder ein
keks dabei wieder die stars blabla
gefressen haben wenig morgen um 9 uhr da
so ich glaube ich um 16 uhr da in diesem
jahr freuen und herzlich willkommen hier
eigentlich zum vierten tag dieser wie
lok reihe mehr oder weniger von meinem
wochenende in berlin
allerdings habe ich mir gedacht ich
schneide das jetzt einfach an den
letzten noch mit dran war heute nicht
viel passiert ich werde jetzt einfach
nur noch ganz schnell zum flughafen
fahren weil mein flieger schon in einer
stunde abschied boarding schon und 20
minuten mann war von hier bis zum
flughafen
40 minuten oder so jedenfalls dachte ich
aus diesem paar szenen die ich hat jetzt
noch film werden kann man keinen
kompletten block noch zusammenschneiden
der den mann dann ein video nennen kann
deswegen parties einfach hier ans ende
von diesem blog vom dritten tag und ich
nehme mich da jetzt mit allen
leider den halben innerhalb meiner
kompletten einfach wegschmeißen möchte
spät kam weil die takte und wir haben
getroffen
ich stehe hier mit
jedenfalls geben jetzt wahrscheinlich
noch etwas zusammen essen also ist und
dann schauen wir mal was sich jetzt noch
für cool wir wollten ein piano sehen wir
einfach hier bei köln messe bauen um
jetzt suchen wir uns eben alles was in
köln city ist ich weiß nicht wo genau
ist aber wir schauen einfach mal ich hab
megawatt auf die not und wieder haben
und da werden wir schön dass speisen auf
was jetzt hier vom heutigen die lok wer
den abschluss wieder wieder gebildet
ich hatte ja jetzt drei blocks machen
den letzten tagen oder die video days
opake vielleicht habe ich jetzt kommt
gleich irgendwie jetzt gerade noch über
die kölner ringe sind es glaube ich und
sonne
irgendwie drauf und bin jetzt noch auf
dem weg
ich habe für diese
das nicht angekündigt
und arbeiten jetzt noch ein bisschen
weiter dran ich hoffe euch haben diese
blogs gefallen der schnitt alles von
sich dann annehmen
eine schau